by the next all you Rick and Morty what
are you guys doing did you develop an
app rule number one and a half
development son never follow the rules
when the role is tattooed on an alien's
forehead - take your app down what I'm
Lee hostage do they have weapons no but
neither do I mean intern okay well who
tells interns what to do but you that's
for sure at the beginning of season four
there's an a slight shift in the
domestic power dynamic that is the head
of the household now and family comes
first suddenly there's a limiter on Rick
when last season Rick was free to do
whatever crap he wanted
we know that Rick pretty much can't die
well that's not true I mean life is
meaningless so when does it ever end or
begin you know say he can't die by
conventional means it's like a vampire
like there are ways to kill vampires
werewolves and Rick I won't tell you and
then on the morty side he had this
crystal and we were like okay how would
morty abuse that she's a good it's sort
of a metaphor for if you are playing it
too careful for your entire life are you
ever really living this is funny that
that leads him into Rick's garage and he
starts him with all this crazy sci-fi
[ __ ] like ferrofluid and the meeseeks
boxes
[Music]
I think you'll be seeing more meeseeks
as time comes what do you want and that
eventually the show will be called
mortium v6 welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this is gonna be my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 2 trailer video
there's also a really big interview that
Dan Justin and a couple of the actors
did talking about season 5 teasers that
they're going to be dropping this season
in a couple of the other big episodes
that'll be coming up so I'll play that
clip in a second if you're brand new to
the channel I'm doing videos for all the
Rick and Morty episodes be sure to
subscribe to get everything we do merch
giveaways every week I'll name a new
giveaway winner at the end of this video
- so obviously episode 2 is going to be
the glooty episode they dropped that big
clip back at Comic Con they joke about
this during the interview clip that I'll
play in a second about why Adult Swim
wanted them to play that clip of all
things because it has something to do
with the way they do merch and they
needed something to sell at Comic Con
it's a really fascinating peek for how
they bring things together the way they
think about actual comic-con trailers so
Dan jokes about them thinking about the
season 5 comic-con trailer for next
summer right now the whole concept of
the gluteus ODE is that Rick wants an
intern or a slave to do menial tasks
that he can't get Morty to do but
because the way glue Dee's species works
they use apps to take over cultures so
Rick basically says glooty is fine as
long as we don't go near this app and
that's why he tattoos that on glue Dee's
forehead but because Jerry's an idiot
and thinks he's going to earn a lot of
money he develops it it's basically an
alien ripoff of tinder that's when
things go completely off the rails you
see them on their ship there and there's
this whole joke about bureaucracy and
intern culture that seems a little bit
like Hitchhiker's Guide but here's the
clip of them talking about future
episodes during season 4 and some season
5 stuff
can we do this Eastern yes Star Trek
which is kind of like a really well-worn
area obviously you're gonna do sci-fi if
you're gonna do comedy you're gonna the
way that's season five though right
is it yeah yeah we're actually okay drop
the season five 2025 I just keep
thinking oh I know one time one it's not
a trope it's more of like homage maybe
the bonding with it okay are you
familiar with a film called alien buckle
in that's true that's know and we just
rerecord I just recorded that's one of
my favorite episodes of the season
that's all I know it's really oh it's
great I mean you guys do this really I
mean I can't say about that what what
came where you like make a duality of a
character like no characters just one
character like every characters gonna
get the option like when summer had the
episode where she was living in the
post-apocalyptic world it was like she
got to like be a different version of
herself in reality so like that nothing
like that it is sort of a theme that
happens often in this next season yes
you're gonna love you'll see you'll
you'll be looking for yeah what can be
called clothes oh we might call it like
Ric Lansing
Ludi is what we had available when the
network needed the name of a character
that they could make new march out of
for comic-con I note to self like for
season five we should be thinking right
now about the comic-con character Jerry
against Rick's direction decides to
develop an app with glooty and all hell
breaks loose in that episode but yeah
like glute glooty glooty is a really
important character he's an intern
he's Rick's intern it really wants to
develop an app I mean you could tell
like Rick is sort of leveraging this
little character he's like he yet he's
he knows the game he knows the bigger
game and he's like yeah you know as long
as we don't develop his app I get I get
a guy that make copies for me and cooks
my food and brings me my syrup so he's
an intern or a slave I guess laughs can
we try I mean Internet Messiah do a
species kidney
the great change it from relations to
app masters yeah that's what happens
blue D comes from a species of alien
there are like there they're a post app
species they've mastered the art of the
app and they use it to enslave well
don't say anymore because now you're
getting too spoilery there is more poopy
butthole coming yeah yeah definitely for
sure and that's I promise you won't get
from a lot of shows this convention
except maybe Riverdale maybe Riverdale
I'm still like obsessed with this this
like tag that's good I wanna I wanted to
record it and sake not I'm like it's me
I can't say this but I don't get to
record it but like it's maybe my most
favorite speech it's so good it's so
good then the response it's just it's so
good finale of season 4 is really good
yeah do we get konami
yeah you have some great character stuff
you've seen these they easy too much you
said too much with that I'm saying
that's a clone so there's a whole lot of
stuff that they reveal during that some
of that is jokes and some of that is for
real like when Justin says no no no
you're definitely giving away too much
about future Beth episodes they
confirmed that there's going to be more
episodes where other members of the
family get to live out completely
different lives like Spencer Grammer
giving the example of Tina Turner summer
from the Mad Max Beyond the Thunderdome
episode living like a member of their
tribe till she went back to her normal
life at the end of the episode love the
way they explained the methodology
behind selling merch at Comic Con like
we need a character which one can we use
to sell the pop for comic-con odd well
we have this glooty character that's why
they picked that clip to release at
Comic Con this summer they talked about
a very special season 5 teaser that
they're gonna drop in one of the season
four post credits scenes a real one not
just a joke one like the mr. poopy
butthole post-credit scenes that they've
had in the finales thus far but they
don't say which episode it's gonna
happen in and it was not the episode one
post-credit scene that we just saw where
morty gets the reveal about what jessica
was really doing in that future that he
saw and when Spencer Grammer gives away
that
almost Beth spoiler and then Dan blurts
out Beth is a clone I obviously think
that the spoiler that she almost gave
away doesn't have anything to do with
Beth being a clone
it's just something special about her
storyline that they sort of started
during season 3 the whole idea that she
could be just as smart urges as special
is Rick I feel like I spent my life
pretending you're a great guy and trying
to be like you and the ugly truth has
always been but I'm not that great a guy
and you're exactly like me so hopefully
we'll wind up seeing a version of Beth
it's a little bit more like Rick than
even this version we saw during season 3
Lake Rick told Jerry
she's Rick's daughter she has options so
there's got to be way more Rick liked
Beth's out there that we just haven't
met yet so everybody let me know in the
comments which episode do you think that
special season 5 post-credit scene is
going to be in and do you think that
it's going to be an evil Morty
post-credit scene because of that 70
episode order I feel like they're not in
any big rush to do the really big
serialized elements that they just did
during season 3 but as they imply during
the season one ending rant where they're
talking about how they're going to do
things going forward some of the
episodes will be serialized so there
will be some continuation of previous
elements like the evil Morty's Citadel
storyline what'll happen is I'll do more
Rick and Morty bonus videos later this
week leave all your requests in the
comments below
the mandalorian episode 1 video will
also post later tonight too so if you
don't have Disney Plus be sure to find
out a way to watch the Mandalorians Star
Wars series there's also a whole bunch
of special Marvel phase 4 footage that
dropped as part of the Disney Plus
release so I'll do videos for that stuff
and all those trailers later this week -
congratulations nug you're the giveaway
winner from my last big Rick & Morty
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 1 video and click
here for my other big Rick & Morty
season 4 trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]